I actually played would you rather
before but I'm eager to switch it to the
director perspective right yeah your
take on some of these yeah first would
you rather screen test your movie or go
with your gut
oh go with my gut yeah I've really
learned to trust my gut and if there's
anything I learned from the book smart
process it's that when your instincts
tell you something is worth being in the
movie fight for it defend it and put in
that movie because it might be that like
only you understand it in the moment but
you know it has a place in the film and
you've got to just trust the audience
will get it is there anything in
particular in this movie that ticks that
box for you
yeah the Barbie trip and the dance
fantasy and the pool scene were three
things that I defended like throwing my
body on the tracks because I was like
these are scenes that I know they seem
kind of extra they seems unnecessary
they don't seem like they further the
plot and yet for me they were integral
to the texture and tone of the movie and
the style - yes just losing the style
there would you rather have enough money
and not enough time or enough time and
not enough money enough money and not
enough time because I believe in paying
people what they deserve and hiring
really really great crew members and
saying I'm going to ask you to work very
hard we don't have enough time but
you're being paid what you deserve
let's give it our all we're gonna work
really fast but you will not be working
for less money than you should be
earning that answer makes me so so happy
would you rather work with a first-timer
who is super enthusiastic or someone
who's a pro but has other things on
their mind first-timer who's
enthusiastic I'm all about working with
people who have something to prove who
really want to be there for their own
reasons because you know as a director
there's only a certain amount of energy
I can have everyone has to have their
own energy and they need to be putting
it into the pot it felt like we were all
operating on this like common frequency
but it was a collective effort and I
could only be in one place at once so I
love knowing when I was shooting a scene
our art department was working their
butts off creating a room and
adding layers to it because they
personally cared and they wanted to show
their work so I'm all about working with
people with enthusiasm even if they've
never been on a job before one more
would you rather for you would you
rather direct something similar to book
smart next or something completely
different
I would love to a combination because I
would love to have the similarity would
have to be the kind of the
professionalism and kindness of the crew
in the cast but maybe a different story
I feel like at its heart it's a
relationship movie and that's the kind
of story I'm interested in telling so I
want to find a different type of
relationship and tell that story